my name is lieutenant richard
r-i-c-h-a-r-d myers
m-e-y-e-r-s and i'm the lieutenant of
our lbmpd sex crime section
thank you for coming out this morning
the reason that we asked each of you to
come here today
was to highlight some of the work that
my section has done
and to reach out and ask for additional
victims to come forward
should there be any the men that you see
here
to my left are men that have con
committed multiple sexual assaults in
the las vegas
valley victimizing numerous female
victims
within our jurisdiction the good news is
that each of these cases has led to the
arrest of these suspects
and they are currently going through the
criminal justice process
in some of the cases victims were
prostitutes
in our area and others not the victims
were not prostitutes
they just happened to be in areas where
prostitution activity occurs
these suspects we believe thought it
would be easy to target these women
and what i'm sure that they didn't count
on was a team of detectives
who were willing to work exhaustively to
bring them
and hold them accountable for the
actions that they occurred
each of these men is considered a
violent predator
and we suspect that there are additional
victims and we're asking them
to come forward with information
at this time these cases all have
similarities
many of these crimes occurred in areas
known for prostitution activity
that's not to say that each of these
victims was a prostitute
it just means that they were in that
area once arrested
the suspects and the investigations that
led to their arrest
show that there was an increase in
violence from the beginning of their
criminal activity
to the time that they were arrested
regardless of the socioeconomic
demographic
or the victims initial willingness to go
forward with their case
an exhaustive investigation occurred in
order to hold these suspects accountable
these investigations included numerous
sections of the lvmpd
to include the homicide sex crimes
bureau the southern nevada
counterterrorism center
the criminalistic bureau numerous lvmpd
patrol area commands
device section the major violators
section
and the lvmpd pio office the other thing
that is unique about some of these
investigations
are that there were citizens who are
willing to see something and say
something
and as we roll into the new year's eve
time of year for the lvmpd
we ask citizens who see something that
doesn't look right
to come forward and pass their
information to the police department so
that we can conduct
investigations on that situation that
didn't look right
these citizens were willing to be good
witnesses and they were willing to
assist with the lvmpd investigations
their cooperation was instrumental in
solving some of these crimes
and finally on december 11 2020
the last suspect that you see there
jorge perez
agreed to meet a female on an online
dating application
once mr perez met the female victim in
the 5000 block of east sahara
he violently sexually assaulted her at
gunpoint
an investigation occurred and mr perez
was located and arrested for that crime
on december 14th we sent out a press
release asking for additional victims to
come forward
because as i stated before each of these
investigations has led
us to learn that many times once a
suspect is arrested for a sex crime
it's not the first time that they've
committed it
the previous investigations let us lead
us to believe that there are additional
victims associated with mr perez
and we're asking anyone with information
regarding mr perez
or any of the other three predators that
you see there on those pictures
to contact the lvmpd sexual assault
section at 702-828-34
or crime stoppers as always with crime
stoppers any information
leading to an arrest and conviction may
have reward money attached to it
and with that i'll take any a question a
few questions
so we haven't seen an increase on sex
worker victims
this is just kind of to show you some of
the work that my section has done
and to let the public know that again
regardless of
the victims socioeconomic
you know background etc the lvmpd is
going to conduct a thorough
investigation
i can so and the lvmpdpio is also going
to provide some information out
the first predator that you see here is
michael nixon
michael nixon committed crimes in
january february and march and was
arrested in march
the second subject that you see there is
jamar reed the investigation into mr
reed began in april
and as we conducted our investigation we
were able to link him back to
approximately eight sexual assaults that
occurred in the area of washington and
i-15
and the third subject that you see there
is louis moreno
louis moreno has now been linked to six
sexual assaults and robberies that
occurred in the lvmpd jurisdiction
all of that information was provided in
previous press releases as well
okay if there's no additional questions
yes ma'am one more question um
so i think some of the key safety steps
that women and men can take in online
dating platforms is to first of all meet
in a public area
um that that is my my best
recommendation for safety whether it be
a local bar
um a local restaurant something of that
nature where the public is around
and then before you move into a private
area with that person that you don't
really know
get to know them first and that that
would be
what i would recommend is you know
keeping that interaction in public until
you're comfortable with that person
last one um
so that's a great question thank you for
asking that sex crimes is different than
any other crime we investigate in the
lvmpd the victim controls the tempo of
that investigation
what i would ask is if they're on the
fence on whether or not to report
come and report and then my detectives
will work with those victims and when
they feel comfortable
for their investigation to go forward we
will activate those investigations and
go forward
all right thank you i appreciate you
guys coming out this morning and have a
safe and merry christmas